dirigirme a las naciones unidas
después de la segunda guerra mundial y
la fundación de las naciones unidas-
estamos una vez más en una lucha global
luchamos contra un enemigo invisible el
virus de china que ha tomado la vida de
más de 188 países
rápidamente creamos una cantidad de
ventiladores para compartirlos con
nuestros socios y aliados a nivel
mundial fuimos pioneros
gracias a nuestros esfuerzos tres
vacunas están en la última etapa de
ensayos clínicos queremos producirlos a
nivel masivo para poder ser distribuidos
apenas se logra distribuimos la vacuna
de error paremos el virus terminaremos
la pandemia y entraremos una nueva era
de prosperidad cooperación y paz
mientras perseguimos este futuro tenemos
que
en el gobierno de china cerro
dejó abierto su espacio pero para poder
impactar y infectar al mundo china
condenó mi decisión de cerrar
los vuelos hacia china y desde china
y la salud pero falsamente que no había
evidencia transmisión de persona a
persona
las naciones unidas deben de vender como
responsable a china por esto este virus
que destruye
el país es uno de los que más afecta la
emisión de carbono es el doble de lo que
emite eeuu y sigue aumentando el
contraste mientras me retiré del acuerdo
de parís
eeuu redujo sus emisiones de carbono más
que cualquier país en el acuerdo de
parís aquellos que atacan a eeuu
mientras ignoran la polución sin
precedentes de china solo quieren
castigar eeuu y yo no voy a apoyar eso
si las naciones unides es una nación es
un órgano efectivo de enfocarse en los
problemas reales del mundo esto incluye
el terrorismo la opresión de las mujeres
el trabajo forzado el narcotráfico el
tráfico de sexo y de personas y en las
persecución de minorías
eeuu va a ser es líder en la protección
de derechos humanos la oportunidad para
los derechos humanos combatir el tráfico
humano y proteger a los no nacidos
también sabemos que la prosperidad de
eeuu es la base de todos en el mundo en
3 años hemos construido la mejor
economía en la historia y lo estamos
haciendo nuevamente nuevamente nuestro
ejército ha aumentado en el en estos
últimos tres años hemos hecho una gran
inversión en los últimos cuatro años
tenemos un gran poder militar y ni
siquiera estamos cerca d
ah
y revitalizamos las relaciones con la
otan por sam reforzamos las relaciones
con méxico el salvador guatemala para
detener el tráfico de personas
[Música]
apoyamos a las personas de cuba
nicaragua y venezuela en su lucha por la
libertad
nos salimos del acuerdo de irán a
acuerdo nuclear de irán
derrotamos a la califato de isis 100%
eliminamos a el líder al bagdadí
y también así como al otro terrorista
que ha visto la imagen
llegamos a un lugar importante de
diálogos en el medio oriente entre
israel
baréin y emiratos árabes unidos quienes
firmaron un acuerdo en la casa blanca
ellos saben que esto es bueno para ellos
y para todo el mundo estos acuerdos
demuestran las diferentes formas de
solución superiores
tratamos de hacer más acuerdos de paz en
el futuro en la región no va a haber más
sangre en la arena esos días ya
terminaron mientras hablamos eeuu está
trabajando para terminar la guerra en
afganistán y traeremos a nuestros tropas
a casa
debemos lograr la paz a través de la
fuerza somos más fuertes que nunca
nuestras armas están en un nivel muy
avanzado como nunca lo habíamos tenido
nunca habíamos tenido este avance y solo
le pido a dios que no no tendremos que
usarlos
pero sólo cuando cuidas cuyás a tus
propios ciudadanos vas a encontrar las
bases seguras y verdaderas para la
cooperación como presidente de rechazado
los errores del pasado y he puesto a los
estadounidenses primero así como ustedes
deberían poner a sus países primero eso
está bien eso lo que deberían hacer
estoy supremamente confiado en que el
próximo año mientras nos reunimos en
persona será uno de los mejores años de
nuestra historia y espero en la historia
del mundo
muchas gracias dios los bendiga dios
bendiga a estados unidos y dios bendiga
a las naciones unidas